Sau khi hoàn tất sách nhận nhẹ học lợt đầu ki tình xin lớp mùi năm 2020 đến 2020,
sự giáo dục ở đào tạo hành lỗi thung báo sẽ tổ chức đợt sách tình bộ sung.
Nhanh tình đủ chỉ tiêu cho các chiều Trung Hoặc Phổ thông công lợp còn thiếu học sinh.
Sách tình bộ sung sự kiến bắt đầu từ ngày mối bày tháng bẩy khi hội đồng sách duyệt học để ra sách chi tiêu còn thiếu và sách định lại mức điểm trình mối phu hợp với tình gình tự tế.
Ngay sau khi hoàn tất, dành sách chúng tình bộ sung sẽ được công bộ công khai trên các kênh thông tin của sử giáo dục ở đào tạo và các chiều.
Được sách tình bộ sung không áp dụ hình thức sách nhận nhẹ học chức tiến.
Giờ đó, học sinh chúng tình cần chức tiếp đến chiều làm tụ tục sách nhận nhẹ học trong khoảng thời gian từ ngày mối xin tháng bẩy đến ngày 2020.
Song sau với khoảng chiến sách tình bộ sung, công tác phút khảo bài thi cũng đang được chiến khai theo đúng quy định.
Kết quả phút khảo sự kiến sẽ được công bố chậm nhất vào ngày 2020 tháng bẩy.
Đối với những thi sinh có điểm thí thay đổi và đủ điều kiện chúng tình sau phút khảo,
thời gian sách nhận nhẹ học sẽ dễn ra chức tiếp tệ trường từ ngày 2020.
Pũ hình và học sinh cần chủ động thật gió thông tin từ sự cũng như từ các trường Trung học phổ thông để không bỏ lưỡ cơ hội nhẹ học vào hệ thống trường công lập.